small businesses are so on the rope
right now and i i wanted to ask you
about this a little bit because
you know in in some of the reading and
writing that i've been doing
like we found that there's been just a
massive transfer
of of revenue of commerce of wealth you
know you have
some of these companies like amazon um
and square and and apple and all these
huge behemoth companies
the two trillion dollar company yeah and
yet
small businesses our data shows that
small businesses are down on average
about 20 plus percent
and 30 have permanently closed at this
point and that's growing
and what i worry about and i want to
know what you think about this is how do
we put that genie back in the bottle
because the trend just seems really hard
right now
you need to dramatically rebalance the
economy if you're going to give small
businesses a chance to
reopen or open a new so you would need
something like universal basic income
honestly to have a shot
because you have apple breaking 2
trillion you have amazon just sucking
so many businesses dry well and i think
the other complicating factor that we
all need to learn together is how does
that process of change
actually happen because i think we get
this wrong i think that there's a
certain segment of the population right
now that thinks like demonizing joe
biden
or donald trump will make that change
happen
but we've had plenty of politicians do
really shitty things
that were worthy of demonization many
times in the past and that
didn't really fix it and i think if
anything we need to try to find a way to
rise above those things and really talk
to each other so
you know for me being from rural idaho a
lot of the people that i grew up with
are are trump maga people um or they're
libertarians or they're people that are
kind of predisposed to not necessarily
uh
want to join some of these solutions
like what you're talking about
and what i'm finding is when i actually
just see them as a human being that's
flawed the way i am that's learning the
way i am
and have a conversation and don't try to
kind of like extricate them from my life
because our beliefs don't line up or the
way we vote doesn't line up and i just
listen to them
we actually can influence each other and
come together
and i think you know we need to be
careful because right now the
the predominant way of persuasion is
kind of by like shaming and bullying
each other
and i don't know if that's going to get
people into the fold of something like
this
i'm pretty sure it's not dan and as
you've
shown for for a long time and we're all
seeing in real time
unfortunately right now like we need
these changes
these changes are not really optional if
we want to protect our way of life
which means using a sub-optimal form of
connection persuasion influence whatever
you want to call it
i don't know that we can afford to do
that right now and so i think a lot of
people kind of on the liberal side of
the equation
you know need to soften up and engage a
little bit more and not be so
kind of like harsh and mean sometimes or
or maybe even find a different way to
frame some of the changes that we're
making you know it's one reason why
uh we christened universal basically
come the freedom dividend is because it
tested better with
broader swaths of the population
i liked it yeah it was hard for me to
switch back i liked it that much and now
we're kind of back to basic income
uh and i actually loved the the freedom
dividend as a branding as a way of
explaining it
well thank you dan yeah yeah no it is
kind of funny
um but i think that language
really helped that make the case to
different types of people there could be
some of your
uh old neighbors in rural idaho would be
like i'm down with the freedom dividend
it's like it's uh and what what you're
describing as like the
the barriers between us and trying to
make the case of different types of
people just like you have these market
incentives around
how companies treat their workers
unfortunately there are market
incentives around politics
where uh political figures get rewarded
more for
ginning up like a passionate group of
people
on a particular side than they do in
reaching out
and solving problems and
that's going to destroy us but but it's
baked into
the way a lot of candidates have to run
where they're much more concerned about
getting primary
primaried by someone in their district
because they're a safe seat
than they are in reaching to out to
different types of people
i mean i i've been trying to write and
encourage people lately like
hey like i get that there's a lot of
horrible things happening
but like putting some focus on the
solutions putting some focus on the
changes that we want to have happen
is really our best bet in this situation
more so than the
you know latest scandal that's going to
keep us kind of all ginned up for an
extra week or two
like these folks who are trying to turn
us against each other like
just ignore them like the fact is we
know how to solve our problems
like you get it i get it we're pretty
much
like the the same with the same
motivations like let's just come
together and get this thing done
well now 55 of americans are for
universal basic income and it's
something like 76 percent are for cash
relief during the pandemic which i have
to say is going to be
uh a natural lead into universal basic
income
uh so so dan what's fascinating is i
feel like you and i
were kind of early on this but now many
many millions of americans have joined
us
and now the big challenges is how the
heck do we restore
the connection between people and
lawmakers where
if enough of us want something it
actually happens and so that's something
i'm now engaged with
very directly because i see that the
mechanics of our democracy are actually
going to be
something we have to solve for and that
also includes our media our social media
it's interesting but i now think that
that's going to be
um one of the foremost challenges to
trying to have something like universal
basic income pass
can you give me a little bit of the
playbook on that because that'll help me
to be out there you know
like walking the walk talking the talk
with you
sure uh so the the first big move would
be something around democracy reform
like ranked choice voting so if you have
ranked choice voting then people
will be able to vote
uh more dynamically you know they they
they wouldn't feel like they were gonna
like waste their vote
uh and then you would make let's call it
uh or the other democrats are
republicans more responsive to different
types of people in their district
because instead of just having to worry
about like someone primary them
it could be that there are a couple of
different points of view that they have
to account for
and so if you're pro democracy then
ranked choice voting
ought to be like a a near absolute good
and and so and it doesn't seem
particularly partisan because it's not
it's like look we should just try and
improve our democracy so it works better
and it's more representative
and you can make very compelling
arguments to people on either side
um that this would just be
a better form of voting so that's one
big
thing that i i'm going to be pushing and
championing because
it's like a process change that strikes
people as
reasonable on both sides yeah well i'm
i'm right there with you and i
completely agree
i think also you know getting money out
of politics is just we got to figure out
a way
i know with the supreme court decision
it's just really hard but like we just
have to do it because it's going to kill
us
that's exactly the kind of change that
we need to to make so i was proposing as
you know 100 democracy dollars for every
uh citizen so that you can just give it
to your favorite
candidate and then all of a sudden we
could wash out the corporate money
so that's a massive change that we need
in the worst way uh i'm for term limits
for
legislators because i just think it's
too easy for someone to go to dc and
then just make it all about
preserving their spot and like climbing
this ladder and the latter unfortunately
stretches up for decades
so if if you dan let's say you were to
do something bold and run for congress
then and win and you know i i would
encourage this actually
so you have a business to run the rest
of it but uh if you were to show up
there then they'd be like oh right now
you're a low man on the totem pole
go like dial for dollars and if you play
your cards right maybe you'll
wind up on one of these awesome
committees in like eight years or
something like that
and so that that that's not helping us
solve these problems
uh and so i think we should have term
limits so that members of congress
see it as a term of service and not like
career then you go there you try and get
something done and you turn around
now there is a balancing act um but to
me that that's
necessary because right now we have
something of a gerundocracy
where the average member of congress i
believe is about 62 years old
which makes them a little bit behind the
curve on technology issues among other
things but
but their their incentives aren't around
solving our problems so much as they are
staying where they are
and and that is something that we need
to address if we're going to
make progress so that so these are some
of the systemic fixes
i'm going to be pushing for um in the
days to come
and hopefully that message first is
needed but hopefully that message uh is
so loud and powerful that we can
override like you know the the software
you know and in your case the
in my case it was like you know it's
like the political software and the
media software and the rest of it that
we have to try and override
um and the interests you know in dc and
the rest of it
uh in economy-wide though it's true that
corporations the the logic of
corporations will
grind us to dust it will end up turning
us into just like these these cogs in
the machine and the machine will
eventually discard us
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode